[Music]
welcome
i'm lou bajic from rstudio thanks for
joining
uh this on demand webinar on
architecting r studio products in the
cloud
today we'll have a couple of people from
our great partner prokagya
oshin bates and kevin bolger who will be
presenting on this topic
this recording is a companion to our
recorded webinar
on what does it mean to do data science
in the cloud if you'd like a bigger
introduction to the subject before
diving into the details here i encourage
you to listen to that first
if you have any questions after the
webinar any technical questions please
go to
community.rtstudio.com we'll have a
thread there to answer questions
if you have any questions about rstudio
products or prokagia services
please contact sales at rstudio.com or
outreach
procagia.com and with that i'll hand it
off to kevin and oshing
thank you lou and welcome to this
webinar on architecting r studio
products in the cloud
and just a quick introduction to our two
presenters there is myself
kevin bulger i'm the director of data
science at procogia
and we also have ocean bates who's going
to be talking us through
some of the tech technicalities of
architecting
for rstudio products in the cloud
just to give a quick overview of how the
presentation is structured
first i want to give a quick
introduction and overview of procogia
what we do and how we work with our
studio
then i'll give a brief overview of how
we tackle
working with companies that want to get
our studio teams
integrated on their cloud platforms some
of the business considerations that go
on there
and also some of the requirements that
we look to gather
when we're trying to architect the ideal
solution for our customers
and then i will pass it over to oshie
and oshie will talk about
the more technical
intricacies of architecting that
solution for our studio teams
environments and
the different solutions that customers
can deploy in the cloud
and after that we will just close up the
presentation
and give out some useful links for
people to
investigate in their own time
so to start with procorgia who are we
and what do we do
taking this from our company's mission
statement we
empower organizations to achieve
sustainable advantage to their data
and we do this by enabling our clients
to make more strategic and intelligent
decisions on their data to implement
their solutions
and we do this with the help of a
diverse team of motivated team players
who love what they do in data science
we follow a pretty standard framework
for how we
implement our solutions and we provide
services end-to-end in the data journey
from advising clients who are just
getting started with their data journey
to
helping them set up their etl workflows
and data warehouses
to reporting on that data and helping to
understand the value that they can drive
from that
and finally helping them with some
prescriptive and predictive analytics
once they get become a little bit more
sophisticated and understand the kind of
outcomes they want to get from their
data
this can be broadly just defined as
following the idoc framework
which looks at first designing your
infrastructure to set up
for proper data analysis perform your
data analysis in the diagnosis
phase optimizing then by using some more
advanced
predictive analytics and finally using
prognosis
step to venture into
prescriptive analytics where we seek to
provide guidance on how
companies can change decisions to affect
the outcomes
and to stay on the topic of our cloud
our cloud journey with our studio
we follow a very similar approach in our
cloud transformation again
consulting with our partners where they
need it to give them guidance and where
they can go
helping them plan and architect those
solutions when they need it and setting
up the infrastructure
to do bi reporting and data science on
top of
and of course then we are full service
partners with our studio
what this means is we are licensed to
resell our studio professional products
and we also have a team of our studio
administrators and instructors
who help work with our clients and work
with different customers of our studio
to design and implement and deploy their
our studio team
suite
who's this webinar fair well if you're
watching this webinar you're most likely
already familiar with the rstudio team
environment
maybe some of your employees or maybe
you yourself
use the software software work but you
want to understand
how you can learn about deploying this
in the cloud and what kind of benefits
that might bring to your organization
and so that's what we're going to
explore within this webinar
and so that brings us to our first
segment of the presentation
on our studio for the cloud
and the first thing we always like to
think about is what are some of the
business considerations so what does
your team
look like and what kind of tools will
they need because
our studio team is quite a diverse set
of tools do they need them all
some of them and what capacity and what
control levels did he needed
so we'd like to use this analogy to
hit home uh how we kind of can look at
different teams and the role that our
studio team can play in that
and this is a very good analogy that a
former prokogya employee
and current staff member of our studio
gagan deep singh
developed for us for a presentation a
little over a year ago and it's
looking at the star trek uss enterprise
team
and how they can be considered an
aspiring data-driven organization
so within the uss enterprise we've got
the blue shirts and these could be
considered analogous to
our data scientists these are logical
tinkers
they seek to understand business
problems translate them into analytic
questions and
perform data wrangling and analysis to
try and build some sort of
advanced use cases on the data whether
it be machine learning or building
dashboards and reports for business
users
so our blue shirts or our data
scientists
are very motivated by getting the most
out of our data
and using the most cutting edge
technologies and techniques
to derive value for them
then we have our red shirts and these
are our mad engineers
our devop engineers and these play a
very crucial role
in a data driven organization they plan
and develop
and test and maintain all of our
enterprise infrastructure
and they build our ci cd pipelines
essentially these are the engineers
these devops engineers who
make sure that everything works the way
it's supposed to work
and that data driven teams have the
tools and technologies that they need to
do their jobs
most effectively so devops engineers
play a very crucial role in a data
driven
team finally we've got the
gold shirts and these are our managers
our analytic managers
our business managers and these are the
powers that be who run
the organizations and
their role is to work with the different
stakeholders and understand
what are some of the business use cases
that the data team can
utilize their data for how can they get
timelines and
allocate their data scientists
effectively towards these and
work with the different senior
stakeholders to make sure that the data
team is
providing adequate value to the company
so again all of these three different
members play
very important roles but they also have
very different
considerations and very different
prerogatives
when we talk about the blue shirts
these are people who want a lot of time
to test models on their own computer but
how can i make it run faster
they want more compute power they also
hear
over here the devops engineers talk
about stuff like jenkins servers but
they don't know what that means to them
so they want some more context there
what why do i care about jenkins
they'll hear about technologies on the
grapevine so they might hear about
kubernetes and how they can make and
process their data faster but
you know they're not trained on how to
utilize that
and finally they they may be interested
in a centralized data platform they
might want to
work with and collaborate with people
across their company and maybe even
across
many sites across the globe
and how can they share their data so
these are some of the considerations
that the blue shirts might have
as for our devops engineers our red
shirts
well they want to make sure that they
can provide as much assistance to the
team as possible but they don't really
know
what the data scientist needs they're
not trained data scientists
they don't know what are the best tools
the most effective tools and
technologies for them
and they just want more time to be able
to to work on this and provide
the most suitable tools to their data
teams
and making sure that nobody's
complaining about lack of compute power
as for our gold shirts they're obviously
interested in how
the team is perceived around the
organization
so are my team able to deliver and work
together effectively
are they able to run and test their
models effectively
time time sensitive manner are they able
to use
all the cutting edge technologies that
our competitors are most likely using
and probably a very common case is
i don't really have the budget to add an
engineer to my team
can i make my teams work more
independently without the need for
adding a new data engineer to the team
so these are all very valid concerns
these three players work together very
well and very effectively
and they can do that with the current
setup but they're missing a command
center
and this is really what's important and
this is what ties everything back
together this command center
and that is what rstudio team suite does
so we've got the rstudio server pro
where data scientists can work together
and collaborate
we've got the package manager which
allows the devops team
to control and make sure that all of the
business use cases or business
restrictions are met and we've got the
rstudio connect where
the data scientists can publish their
results and share them out with all the
different stakeholders in a really
effective manner so it's a fully
integrated environment
that allows everybody to work together
in a seamless way
so you might ask yourself then why would
i want to use the cloud why
not just deploy this on a local
environment in a
on-premise server so
for those who are uninitiated with the
cloud i'll i'll take it slow
there are some major benefits to using
the cloud one of the
most cited use cases is that you get to
pay as you go
or rather you only pay for what you need
you also lower your total cost of
ownership so you're not paying for
massive overheads
you take a lot of the guesstimating out
of your work
so you can plan scalable infrastructure
you can focus more on innovation as
opposed to managing and maintaining
expensive infrastructure and you can
utilize the global networks and ever
expanding global networks of different
cloud providers
to make sure your teams across the globe
can interact with each other
this is very important for large data
science teams that are spread out across
many different
sites across the globe
diving a small bit deeper into the pay
as you go model what does it mean
well you trade in that expensive and
rigid on-premise hardware for
more highly available cloud
infrastructure only paying for what you
use no more or less
and so many providers provide this
this model and this means there's a very
low or
sometimes even no upfront cost so with
some service providers you'll even get a
free tier where you can experiment with
the different services and see if they
meet your needs
and you can follow this graph here kind
of portrays a very
basic model of how cloud costs can
compare to
very strictly managed on-premise costs
so as demand rises for on-premise
servers the engineers will
have new servers spin up over time
and then once demand drops they'll have
to drop down that demand and
so on and so forth throughout the over
time so this obviously leaves a massive
amount of delta
uh if you overestimate you're obviously
paying for more compute than you need
and if you underestimate sometimes you
won't have enough compute power to meet
the demand
with the cloud you don't have to worry
about that everything is scalable
everything's automated
and it can always meet the demand as
it's needed
and this is thanks to the great scale
that cloud providers are able to provide
you lower your total cost of ownership
so diving a small bit deeper into this
one
you can think of cloud providers as like
i said being able to
benefit from the massive scale of having
millions of customers
and so they you don't need to dedicate
specialists to maintain on-premise
infrastructure and replace broken parts
and faulty parts
cloud providers take care of this
completely
so all you have to worry about is
configuring your infrastructure
so cloud runs high volume low margin
business model that means they're
passing those savings on to you as well
so again because of that scale they can
just achieve a cost efficiency that is
pretty much impossible at a local
environment level
so this drastically reduces the cost of
ownership and
if you go to the link i have attached
here you'll see a diagram
that just compares the costs between
on-premise and and then cloud and you
can think of it like an iceberg where
you have the tip of the iceberg that
many people see and compare and contrast
the two but
with on-premise there's a lot of stuff
hidden beneath that iceberg
going back to our previous chart where
we can see the different
costs and how you can be a bit more
accurate with cloud
this is because we can take that
guesstimating out of things we can scale
up and down our servers if we need
larger machines or smaller machines
we can use clusters to scale out and in
our
resources as needed so if we're using
elastic mapreduce for example if you
have
very large data and you're not going to
be ever
left with underutilized idling
infrastructure
your infrastructure is going to be used
100 as you need it so long as you can
figure it that way
so that leaves full control over to us
and completely reducing that idling time
to zero
and of course not having to manage all
that infrastructure
and not having to pay massive overheads
for large compute machines and clusters
it means we can focus more on innovation
and i've
taken some inspiration here from a
previous cloud presentation i saw
and what we see here is if we look at
our on premise
we have the ability to experiment a lot
less frequently and this is because
the kind of clusters that we need to do
really advanced experimentation are
very expensive not just to provision but
also to maintain
and we've got to have dedicated
engineers monitoring the health
status of these so that means failure is
quite expensive if we
experiment and resolve nothing
that's a lot of cost incurred for that
experimentation
so as a direct result of this many
companies see less innovation occurring
on their on-premise servers however
contrast that with cloud and we can
experiment very often again
because of that low cost because you can
get started for virtually nothing
and scale up and scale up your your
costs as needed
so because of that because of the lower
cost of failure
it means that more innovation can occur
you can try out more models
you can try out new and different
services if they don't work for you
you can move on
and finally the last component that i
think is really important for cloud
infrastructure
is it really makes maintaining
global teams a lot easier with the cloud
there's
no need to limit yourself to one
location you don't need to set up
multiple data centers across the globe
you simply take advantage of the cloud
providers
already existing infrastructure
this means we can combat latency by
having duplicated versions of
our infrastructure in many different
regions
and setup time can be completely
automated to ensure consistency so
if there's very strict requirements
on how the infrastructure is to be set
up we can automate that
using different scripts
so that's a little bit about some of the
business considerations as to why you
would use rstudio and
why you might want to consider using it
in the cloud
next i want to talk about how we gather
some requirements and this is just a
brief
overview of that
and so we like to consider each
component of the rstudio team family
as separate components that require
separate considerations
so when we talk about pro we're talking
about the data scientists we're talking
about their use cases
and we're trying to understand what is
the makeup of this team
how many users do they have you know
that have data scientists analysts
machine learning specialists
what kind of computation are they doing
is a very high computation model are
they doing
lots of simulations is the data that
they're
working with is it quite large is it
small is it
highly dimensional and that gives us an
idea and we can start to process
just how large a compute needs to the
need you can even compare to some of
their on-premise use cases you know what
do they use on-premise what do they see
in their local environments how how does
their current setup
meet their needs is it too much is it
not enough and we can use this
information to
architect a solution for them that's
suitable
we do a similar thing for connect but of
course this is a business-facing
application so
the kind of things we're interested in
here we're interested in you know how
many people are going to be consuming
the reports
how broadly within the organization are
we going to disseminate these reports
who's going to have access to it what
kind of reports do we
envisage we're going to be utilizing on
connect
are we going to be building just
dashboards are we going to be using
markdown reports
are we going to use plumber apis that
different data scientists are going to
hook into
so these are important uh considerations
and of course we want to know
is this traffic going to be predictable
are people based all over the globe and
for that reason we're going to see lots
of traffic at different times during the
day
or are they all based in one location so
we can anticipate that at night time
we're going to see a dip in traffic and
during the day time or around certain
times a day we're going to see
high peaks and traffic
so again these are some of the
considerations that we we look into
when trying to figure out just what kind
of rstudio connect
server setup needs to be implemented
and finally we look at rstudio package
manager
and we we try to understand at what
level and this is more for the devops
people
at what level do they need to understand
or control packages that are being
utilized
by the data scientists so are they work
in a controlled environment is it a
gxp compliant environment do we need to
restrict access to the internet
or are they allowed to access publicly
available repos
do they need to use non-standard
libraries like the bioconductor
library of course they'll probably need
to use crown but we can double check
that
do they need to hook into packages from
github others
how much do we want to control and
restrict what our
users do and do not do inside of our
environment and we can control all of
that through
our studio package manager in
collaboration with the
rstudio server
with that being said uh i'll hand it
over to the very capable hands of oshie
bates
and he will go into more of a technical
deep dive on
the different architectural
considerations for
arsenal team in cloud
thanks kevin so i'm going to run through
um
the sort of architecture side a bunch of
the questions that we
sort of run through ourselves as we're
moving on to the architecture and
deployment of an rstudio solution
um for a typical client
so we're going to approach this through
the lens of amazon web services
but all of the content that we cover
here is
transferable mostly and applicable
conceptually to other cloud service
providers
so if someone says to me you know
they're interested in architecting in
the aws
in ecosystem and they're unsure where to
start
i typically advise the well architected
framework
it outlines five pillars operational
excellence
security reliability performance
efficiency
and cost optimization
we build out um an architecture
we usually periodically check and we say
okay how does this
uh how does this compare to the
five pillars um that we're striving for
if you are interested
um the
uh so
uh if you're new to the well
architecture framework i would highly
recommend
amazon's kindle app or kindle reader
uh one of the big benefits of that is
that you have
the community contributed
uh highlighting
of the you know very popular sections of
the framework so
in terms of moving on the next question
you're probably going to have
is server size so as a general rule of
thumb
for connect and server pro you're going
to estimate your size
both on the number of concurrent user
sessions you expect
and the estimated size of these sessions
um with package manager you're going to
scale more so
probably in terms of disk size you're
going to be looking more at okay
adding um additional packages over time
perhaps not um additional users
um it would not scale perhaps in the
same way obviously individual use cases
will will
vary in terms of connect and server pro
then
as kevin touched on we're looking more
so at uh
okay how many end users do we have what
sort of applications will they be
running
um and then based on those
criteria we would recommend and you know
you'd scale the cores from maybe
8 to 16 to above um
gigabytes of ram you know you might
start somewhere closer to 32 you might
scale up
um into three figures
high availability typically we go for
high availability as a best practice
uh regardless of the number of users um
but certainly as your workloads get uh
larger and your number of users get
larger
it makes sense to split among uh across
multiple machines
so here is a table which just gives a
overview
this is taken from a very useful rstudio
article um so yeah just covering
covering more of the same um and
obviously these are
recommendations as you really dig into
the granular aspects of your
own organization's use case you may find
the need to
tune and tweak as needs be
so one of the jokes we have is that you
dress for the team that you want not the
team that you have
so um you know that that
essentially means a plan for scaling and
invest in a scalable architecture
during the planning stages because
it makes a lot more sense to plan in
advance
than to worry later that you uh
that you didn't take the necessary steps
in the planning and deployment stages um
to facilitate a team that could have
grown
um grown over time so it certainly pays
to uh
measure twice cut once to plan in
advance and to
plan for something that can scale as
your team scales
um one of the things that we recommend
is that uh you are a truly data driven
organization so
it's not just um analyzing
[Music]
and working with the uh
the data that you're uh that justifies
you know having an airstudio but also
the data that is created by
rstudio itself so uh
you have a few options here um there is
built-in monitoring
in all our studio professional products
um
our studio will write to a round-robin
database file on each machine
that gives options for creating custom
reports or custom analysis
there are options in addition to that in
terms of integration with external tools
such as
prometheus and graphite
and then aside from that you have
multiple layers that you can tap into so
you have the rstudio layer
of data you also have services in your
cloud infrastructure provider
if it was amazon it would be amazon
cloudwatch
and with this data then
ideally what we try to aim for is some
level of automation
to keep your stakeholders informed that
could be scheduled that could be
daily weekly monthly depending on your
specific use case
i guess yeah the takeaway is just
you have this data try to make the most
of it
and then yeah informed decisions are the
best decisions
in terms of the options that you have
for provisioning
our studio environments these are some
of the main ones that we
find ourselves discussing with clients
so
you know you can use an amazon machine
image that's sort of a bundled packaged
um
[Music]
our studio image that is sold via
the marketplace in the case of amazon
yeah
amazon web services marketplace
you can easily deploy a our studio
machine with with a few clicks
it's very rapid it has some pros and
cons which we'll jump into in a future
slide
um in terms then of other options
you can do a manual install
shell commands in your ec2 terminal
you could choose to automate those same
commands
via a build automation
tool like um or language
like ansible cloud formation scripts
terraform etc
and then i suppose docker similarly
takes that to containerization so
there are a number of container
orchestration services
and frameworks we're going to look
primarily at kubernetes
there are additional options outside the
scope of this
presentation all right so
in terms of yeah common types
environments we look at
you have traditional ec2s maybe with or
without a load
bouncer depending on your requirements
the benefit then
of um kubernetes is that
your same ec2 servers
are managed by a container orchestration
service
in the case of amazon web services there
are multiple options
but the safest option if you're unsure
is elastic kubernetes service
and what that is going to do is that it
will
manage your ec2s and if there are
issues with the health of a specific
node or server it will um
it will manage that for you know it will
spin up an equivalent
and you'll have higher availability as a
consequence
so recently
um relatively recently our studio have
launched
um additional features upon pun intended
i guess
server pro launcher so um
with with launcher now you can
you can hook into a container
orchestration service like
uh kubernetes or slurm
and for each user session
that's going to be launched with a pod
like a kubernetes pod
and uh you can choose then with launcher
you know you can
have your regular r studios sessions
also you can
utilize uh jupiter so a bit more on that
in a moment finally i just wanted to
cover
a specific use case that we have
worked we have worked on with
some clients this is more something that
you would use if you had a need to i
guess
more so than seeking it out but it is it
is a really elegant solution that for
the right
organization that needs it can provide a
really
valuable efficient streamlined solution
and that is
when you have the necessity for sort of
a clean room scenario
uh ephemeral storage you know you don't
want your sessions persisting
you need to know that when your employee
sort of figuratively closes the door on
that clean room and terminates the
instance
that uh that everything is gone that
everything is compliant
and typically you know we'd approach
that with a
script like a scripting approach like
amazon cloudformation
in conjunction with a container image
like a docker image
and then amazon web services service
catalog
is like an interface for people to uh
to add a click of a button spin up a
yeah clean room environment to a very
specific
criteria and a deep dive of service
catalog is outside of the scope
of this but if this sounds like
something you're interested in
i'd highly recommend doing a deep dive
on it it has
a lot of powerful permissions to
you know to limit what your users can
and can't do
what they can and can't spin up um just
they're just a really useful service
that we're quite keen on
so in terms of considerations when
you're launching
an amazon machine image there are a few
sort of use cases that we see people uh
typically
going with an ami for you've got your
proof of concept environments
you've got rapid prototyping
and uh yeah typically if like pocs
anything sort of short term it makes
sense in ami
but over time you want to be conscious
of the breakpoint
at which it's less practical
and it makes more sense to buy a yearly
license
so this varies depending on the image
you're going with
but if you run the numbers it can it can
typically become
apparent when it makes sense to uh
to make the jump from quick ami to
investing in a in something more
long-term
so there are many considerations when
you're
sort of weighing up whether it makes
sense to
go with the traditional ec2 install or
managing fire containers this list and
comparison is certainly not
exhaustive um
these are some of the considerations we
find ourselves discussing
and i'd certainly would recommend to
dig into this a bit more if you find
that you're not
really leaning towards one or the other
so in terms of containerization
if if there's like someone really on the
fence uh
we typically like to go with
containerization
um because over time
it you know it does pay it does pay
dividends um
so some of the sort of considerations
for containerization
you know you can once you've done the
initial groundwork you can spin off
jupiter notebooks instances uh our
studio
instances um in just just a few seconds
or minutes
um you can decrease the time needed for
deployment and testing um because
your environments are going to be very
consistent wherever you uh wherever you
spin it up everything is
specified in the in the code in the
docker file
and the related files that build your
docker image
or your container image they give
more granular permission to yeah
infrastructure is code allocate
resources
and spin it up across various computers
environments systems
testing and debugging typically
it's a bit more straightforward you know
the same reason you can uh
ideally you can write once run anywhere
obviously
same as with java that really wants one
any
one everywhere anywhere doesn't always
work but uh
rule of thumb yeah big value there
over time containers you know as i said
it's going to be more cost effective
and it will decrease the development
cost
beyond that obviously
there are still scenarios where it makes
more sense to go with
a traditional ec2 install in the short
term
it can be quicker uh
for someone who isn't familiar with
containers
maybe a more traditional system
administrator who hasn't made the jump
to containers
it's easier they can ssh in they can
play in the shell they can
they can quickly prototype hack
um and troubleshoot
in terms of simple configurations then
you know you have uh
if we're doing high availability we just
have our load balancer we have the main
node
and then we have uh we can add on
additional nodes via the our studio
configuration files
um and we don't have to worry about
the low bouncer because the point of
entry is just the main note
so scaling as well um
i guess yeah the the side effect of that
is that it's
limited by the load bouncer in terms of
scaling options
so yeah as i said these are
these are some of the considerations we
have
your mileage may vary your scenarios may
vary uh hopefully
this is a foundation
that will start uh you know getting the
thoughts processing
and help you to sort of formulate your
own questions about
what makes sense for your organization
what trade-offs should you
be thinking of and yeah what makes the
most sense for you
so in terms of docker resources
in a lot of scenarios you know you will
find that that you may need to roll your
own
but in terms of starting points there
are some great
initiatives ongoing our studio currently
um primarily ubuntu
so our studio has a a bunch of
their own docker docker projects ongoing
there are docker files specific to uh
the server pro launcher use case there
are docker files of the entire
our studio um you know an entire
studio product to spin up a standalone
environment as opposed to integrating
with uh with launcher for a session so
like session versus
um an entire environment
and then uh yeah there are
opinionated sets of our binaries
and they they are more like the building
blocks like i was alluding to
from which you would you would build out
your own specific environment
in terms of community then the rocker
project has
a lot of popularity
you might find uh specific use cases
um for you know community versions or
uh yeah things outside of our studio
professional
and then our hub initiative of
our consortium and these are images
which are aiming to replicate the
environments
that are used for testing cran cran
packages
so similarly this isn't an exhaustive
list these are some of the main
projects ongoing you may find something
completely fit for purpose or you may
need to
adapt it but certainly a good place to
start
if you are unsure in terms of package
management
there are a few options
so package manager uh rstudio.com
this is a relatively new initiative
this is our studio public package
manager
i believe there's a single github repo
currently there
git source and beyond that it is
uh cran uh
so it's not my place to speak of you
know future development efforts
um i cannot say but
it's an awesome resource for now um
depending on your use case it may or may
not suit
for many of our enterprise scenarios to
date at least we found
the need for sort of an internally
hosted package manager
server and some of the use cases that we
encounter with that
are you know
they might have internal packages they
don't want to share publicly one of the
really useful things we can do um with
package manager for that
is that we can configure the
git repo endpoints and then we can set a
polling interval
it defaults to five minutes and then our
the rstudio package manager server is
going to pull
each get endpoint at the interval and if
it
if it picks up on any changes
in terms of triggers of commits or tags
you can set
committer tag it's going to rebuild so
in terms of an integrated development
environment
that's hugely beneficial you know you
can have your dev team
pushing and then package manager is
going to rebuild
uh is going to rebuild within sometimes
you know within five minutes
um depending on depending on your
interval
obviously um building tara.g sources
is beneficial also typically
if we can we try to get everything into
git um it's just a nicer automated
solution
uh so by the time you're watching this
webinar
uh hopefully uh our studio packs manager
reverse
version 1.2 will be released and a big
uh value added that is improved support
for bioconductor packages
and python so the caveat with python is
that for this release it will be a beta
um but yeah
in terms of right now beta i guess
some of the caveats are that you you
cannot
create a curated subset for this release
um so that can that can be a bit
of an overhead in terms of disk space
again uh just want to flag these and
these new features not to speak on
behalf of the r studio team themselves
these are considerations that we have
and value that we have found and for the
most up-to-date
news on uh cutting-edge features and new
releases
obviously um follow
your uh your preferred rss feed or email
list etc
uh to get the updates from from the
horse's mouth per se from
from the r studio team so in terms of
user authentication
you've got a bunch of options i guess
one thing to flag that's not covered in
this in this overview is that uh
what we notice working with some of our
some of our clients is that they don't
um i suppose one of the recurring things
is just that
they don't and realize or
their assessment team don't realize the
necessity
to have user folders on server pro
so um the way that
the server pro
that your server pro setup will look is
necessary to have
an authentication um protocol
architected that will allow for the
creation of user folders
in the home directory in your in your
machine's home directory and
if you don't plan for that um it can be
a
frustrating use case to backtrack
um
just in case you're at a risk of
forgetting
uh that is that is something something
necessary so
we have a few options here um
[Music]
in terms of proxied authentication
that's something that we would recommend
that you only look at um typically if
you really have a compelling use case to
require it and if you are happy to take
on the administration
that comes with maintaining an external
proxy server for authentication or proxy
service
cool so in terms of
data storage considerations we have a
few options
um
typically if you're doing high
availability you're going to
require postgres um
that's that's a recommendation sqlite
is an option but it's going to store on
the
uh on your server itself so if you are
doing sqlite
um in a high availability you're going
to look at
the share drive so
nfs typically you know you'll have an
nfs mount and you're going to want to
make sure that
your each machine within your ha
setup is writing to the same point so
that you don't have a
separate files for each server i believe
that there is postgres support coming
for server pro
in a future release but again
i don't want to speak on our studio's
behalf
i believe it is coming we have we have
uh
we have asked for it and we have
suggested that it is of interest but
uh yeah again refer to our studios
documentation
and latest uh releases for
definitive um
definitive news on that in terms of then
where the different data variables are
going to be set
i alluded already to nfs
so if you have high availability you're
going to need a
shared source data source
at which all of the individual servers
are going to write
so for connect package manager server
pro
the traditional option is an nfs
file mount with package manager now
recently
there is the added option of using an
amazon s3 bucket so
if you're completely uh
adverse to using amazon web services
there is not currently an equivalent uh
but if you are using aws s3 is an option
there are a few different considerations
in terms of benchmarking
you you can jump into them a bit more
as they're sort of separate from the our
studio here itself
but typically for us some of the
things we're looking at are okay
the s3 option is going to use the s3 the
aws
sdk whereas nfs will mount directly on
your file system
whereas s3
has uh the potential for cost savings
as um in comparison to to nfs
obviously similarly i'd advise
doing some research beyond the scope of
this webinar
to truly decide which use case suits
your organization better
so there are a number of options for
odbc connections our studio has a really
useful
tool in the
sense of their professional drivers
you've got a lot of the main use cases
covered here
one question that we have heard more so
since
snowflakes ipo is a snowflake
integration
for now the snowflake odpc documentation
it's perfect it works we have mentioned
to our studio you know
that the addition of snowflake to the
odp to the professional drivers
uh would be
would save us a few minutes of work um
again i can't speak for our studio it
may come in the future
uh but for now you know if you're
looking at snowflake it's it's not a big
deal to uh
to spend a few minutes more their odbc
documentation is perfect fit for purpose
um
yeah no worries on that end there are
additional tools that you can look at
one of our favorites is sparkly or and
this provides
the sort of deep player vocabulary that
a lot of our
clients and peers are used to coming
from
the tidy verse and that provides that as
an r interface to apache spark
so there are some really good um our
studio webinars on the sparkly or
project that i would highly recommend
if you have an apache spark use case
if you have an apache spark use case
apologies um
that can be cut as uh as suits
okay so i pulled this headline
from a similarly named identical into
him to our studio uh
webinar and press release um i love
story
we sort of joked on some of our slide
decks then uh
our studio and procagia a love story
it's uh yeah
it's uh yeah it's always a it's always a
funny one anyway so
in terms of in terms of python and ir
you have a few you have a few options
and a whole lot of um
[Music]
you have a few choices and a whole lot
of options so
firstly if you're architecting an
rstudio environment you're going to ask
yourself okay
does it make sense to or do we have the
requirement
and the desire to have a
set up with our studio launcher where we
can launch jupiter lab and jupiter
notebook sessions
or are we um
are we content with the very capable
approach of using a package like
reticulate uh
i should add actually to this slide you
know you have external
cluster resource managers that's
typically how we would approach it but
you also have
local launcher as well so in terms of
python development outside of jupiter
we have the reticulate package which is
hugely beneficial
then we have our host of
different our interfaces like
the apache interface that we mentioned
in the previous slide so you know you
have tensorflow
keras and i can only imagine as the
community continues
at the cadence that it is that there
will be
more exciting releases in future
so in terms of connect you have a host
of deployment options
we've worked with with clients who have
been deploying
react.js apps and there's a
there's a whole world of opportunity out
there in terms of deploying to
connect obviously
there are some scenarios that uh
you know you may find that it doesn't
make sense to publish your content to
connect there may be a use case
uh outside in terms of stuff outside of
our that's what i should say so
you know connect is fantastic for r and
python
we see people using javascript um
publishing javascript
that may or may not be uh that may
not be perfectly suited
i guess what i'm trying to say is i am
not i am wary of selling
uh i studio connect as a one for all
uh deployment option for every single
possible web application
i just uh yeah we've been excited by
some of the things that we see the
community doing with our studio connect
so i wanted to uh
to mention the opportunities rather than
to sell it
as a one for all solution for any
possible web app you could dream up
so edge cases aside
um for our content and python content
you have
a lot of great options
in terms of python some of the main sort
of
publication options and approaches that
we see currently
you have support for flask you have
support for plotly dash
and then you can really hack here and
augment your r work
with the reticulate package be it
our markdown reports and shiny
applications
so what what are we getting at with with
this discussion of
connect i'm you know what i'm trying to
say here is uh
that there are a lot of options out
there
that connect makes possible and
yeah you have you have some great
options here and just try to consider
them
as you are building out your
architecture
so i'm not sure if uh
if uh everyone in the audience will have
uh recalled the
disney movie the film of dreams but um
yeah there's a there's a quote from it
that if you build it they will come
and uh
yeah so we're not we're not uh
we're not suggesting it will play out
exactly like the the movie the field of
dreams
where a bunch of baseball players will
turn up and start using your our
environment
but uh it's a it's a great mantra
that that we try to uh that we try to
live by when we're architecting so
in a lot of our organizations um
depending on the organization all of
your colleagues may not be fully sold on
are yet they may not be our users
but in architecting your environment
there's huge opportunity to
get new users on board be they
you know they may become fully fed our
users they may just
integrate with your system whatever the
level is
to to meet them at um
you know if you can be an our evangelist
and think of all the ways that your
architecture can hook into
new or pre-existing infrastructure
within your organization
or a partners organization there there's
huge powerful
to build really um
you know scalable adaptable
plugable architectures um and that's a
huge value of the cloud you know you can
architect rapidly
you can fail often and you can yeah you
can really build out some exciting
uh exciting distributed systems um
cool so finally
yeah being an end-to-end architect
that's that's sort of
what we're getting at with the previous
slide also
as you're building the architecture it's
easy to focus on
solely you know the rstudio side of
things or
what your our users are going to do but
there's a huge
um wealth of opportunity for
integrating and collaborating with with
your entire organization
and there are countless
possibilities both native to our studio
products
and community offerings that you can
harness to uh to really build a really
powerful
and capable our studio environment
that can provide huge value to your
[Music]
organization